انا في مركز في مخيم كبير في اديونت وان
في غرفه العمليات المركزيه التابعه للبحث
التونسيه والتي هي مربوطه امامي مباشره
على الشاشه بغرفه العمليات المركزيه
التابعه للامم المتحده في تركيا والتابعه
ايضا المربوطه مباشره لغرفه العمليات في
جنيف ساذهب مباشره الان ماذا يجري على كل
الاراضي التركيه وايضا على كل المواقع
التي نحن بها جنرال مباشره رقم 230 وال 44
ماذا يعني
هو عدد المواقع البحث والتفتيش تم فتحها
منذ حدوث الزلزال في تركيا الى 203 اعداد
اوكي هي هي مواقع الناشطه الان النشيطه
يعني الان هنالك 44 موقع يعمل به في كل
الاراضي التركيه نعم
موقع يعمل فيهم حاليا في تركيا جنرال 702
ما هو هذا الرقم
انتشاله وهم من تحت الانقاذ من اللي فتح
الموقع هذا وقامت بتركيز الموقع هذا الى
هذه اللحظه على 702 تم انتشار جنرال الرقم
من 479 والرقم 207 ما هو 207 20
كامم متحده وككل فرق دوليه موجوده نعم
لواء الامم المتحده هي خاف بانتشال
الاعداد
من تحت الانقاذ 407 ما هو عدد الموتى الذي
تم انتشاله من تحت الانقاذ من قبل الفرق
تحت لو المتحده جنرال لو نذهب الان بهذا
التوقيت المباشر ماذا يجري على كل الاراضي
التركيه الان كم دوله تشتغل الان كم فريق
فرق الدوله الفرق
144 فريق يشتغلوا على الاراضي التركيه
وفهم عشرين فريق اخرين عبروا على سعادتهم
قادمين لتعزيز المجهود هنا في تركيا اذا
ذهبت الى الصوره المباشره على الفرق التي
تعمل الان في كل الاراضي الان اريد
المدينه التي نحن بها
نعم كل فريق عنده ايديه عنده تعريف نتاع
المتحده التعريف هذا يكون موجود على
الخريطه وبالتالي نعرفوا كل فريق دولي
ملتوي تحدي وين موجود بالضبط تشتغل منطقه
اليمن ونحن مجدين اذا سمحت غرفه العمليات
بس فقط
الفرق التي هي منتشره بكل احياء المدينه
انتم تعلمونها ومرتبطه بكم بالتحكم
والسيطره مباشره على كل الاراضي التركيه
ضمن مظله جنيف التي تراقب غرفه عمليات
مركزيه هيك افهم منك
ساذهب معك الان نخرج من عمل من العمليات
الميدانيه التي تجري في هذا التوقيت الى
عمليات انتشال الجثث خليني اذهب معك الى
الدول مباشره جنرال اذا سمحت سريعا كيف عم
يصير التنسيق الان والدول التي سحبت الجثث
من اول دوله
الدوله عندها اعداد ممكن اكبر في سحب
الدوله الجزائر بحكم الموقع متاعها وتوقيت
الوصول متاعها ثم تلقى الترتيب بتاع
الاحصاء حسب الدول بتقوم بانزال الاعداد
متاعها في التطبيق خلينا نذهب الجنرال الى
الدول اذا سمحت مباشره كيف تجري كيف سحبت
الجزائر بعد ذلك الجزائر 109
تشيكاريا صفحه 47 تركيا 47
بلغاريا صفحه 43 فرنسا 42
مصاب
الهند 42 تونس 26 روسيا 25
الماليزيا 21
بولونيا 21 ايطاليا 18 والاردن 16
تبعات تبعات لحتى نصل برايك جنرال التحكم
والسيطره بين الامم المتحده من جهه وبين
تركيا من جهه وبين كل القيادات التي هي
على الارض برايكم من خلال تجربتكم هل هي
ممسوكه يعني
نعم
زميلتي في الاستديو تقول ما هي المواقع
التي لم تنشط يعني المواقع التي لم تذهب
الى اذا صارت خلينا نذهب الى في اول في
اول الى المواقع الاساسيه الان الان نحن
نتحدث عن 44 الان في مواقع تعمل عليه هل
هنالك من مواقع لم يعمل عليها لكل المواقع
القادمه عليها تم توزيع الفرق القادمه ل
140 فريق على كل المواقع التي تم
مسها الزلزال كل المواقع مشتغله وكل
الاماكن الاماكن اللي تم الوصول اليها